yeah literally gonna edit this and post
this this afternoon do get ahead of my
work so this is scrambling last minute I
know I would have came what my parents
were busy getting drunk in my house
so Vidya what happened yesterday haze
happened yesterday and Kingsley is a
music prince not Prince a musician but
he is just royalty in the music world
I got a dark yep he's gonna help me
judge the red carpet fashions at the
AMAs you saw some of it a vocalist
like the vocals at the beginning Kelly
Clarkson Demi so good glad to hear
what'd I miss
let's get into these fashion Lord oh man
oh he went blonde but this is cute
this is very I will say Larimar 30-30
premier oh my god hilarious Jackie from
the Rugrats not even up Jennifer Tilly's
Chucky's bride dollar very complimentary
to miss Selena Gomez yes oh wow people
are going crazy yeah you know who is BTS
is like biggest fan
Harley Morenstein
[Music]
I don't know much about them other than
their kpop super star Bam Bam I know
their fans are super dedicated always
yelling at us like react to them itself
but I'm just like I can't I like that
they're bringing back like 90s de la
boîte hair name sometimes what I think
Hannah looks like I also do like that
they're kind of doing a matching ish
coordinating things girl we're really
miss Ross herself she was honored
I kind of love it she doesn't give up
she's showing up in some sort of Cirque
du Soleil I'm Saul bunch of photos I
think I have a better one in my fantasy
now we have our daughter Tracee Ellis
Ross so this is what she walked in the
color is great your taste in movies is
Kelly Clarkson this is gorgeous
see I think this is very like just
demure what's to me like very elegant
like Oh definition but also she looks
like your aunt that drinks a ton that is
recently divorced that came to the
wedding together
now looks like an investment banker
invest in my finances this looks like a
very nice soup for some reason he looks
a little likes coming to me yeah he's
like a wolf of Wall Street looking I can
get with that
did you see the war Austria no I've
never seen any movie that you've seen
you know scummy
investment bankers well okay that could
starve Josh
love this amazing it's so confusing at
first when you see it but it's also
perfect it looks like he climbed out of
the backdrop looks like he's like the a
disco car wash your car can go right
through the center those legs and come
out the other side clean this is just a
perfect photograph motion like living
you always find a wrap to match can feel
Dean I'm Patti Stanger those names the
girl from the thing I think this looks
really cool I just always see her as
like a wholesome girl from pitch-perfect
slightly weird to look at someone that's
like very cute seeing so many other
worlds try and be like a badass oh hi
honey is she trying or she succeeded oh
I think that like a bra so stuck on and
I love that wet hair look I don't know
it's called it's called like a WWE male
wrestler was that every award show all
the time no one knows exactly why but
they let her be there she still what
seal no this looks like vagina something
like unreal there's cobwebs and stain on
her laurels fantasy leg
we can't block them from stranger things
the kids from stranger things always
look cool red carpet no effortless
what's this play was he doing play I
don't know the pose is a little like the
beginning of a Disney music it's a lot
of dress is it pink
it looks like coral on this photo but
you know knows she's not pink hair this
is Jim it's very feminine and I'm just
so used to seeing pink being like a
badass how the blue oh that's cute Tommy
oh yes hmm he looks like kind of like a
Billy Ray Cyrus I love your country
Edward Teller oh very white yes
guys need to take more rest yeah like
we're missing like a Pharrell or like
somebody to go natural shooter Demi
Lovato I didn't even recognize this was
her at first I can't with her she has
been killing every appearance she's made
since like January this is like Elvira
but like now I love this inches trend
that's happening what's that just where
the weave and the extensions are just
like down but to your kneecaps of hot
where's your extensions
marshmallow I honestly thought this was
a headless person backdrop Nick diamond
you wanted someone to kick up the men's
looks a knotch
I got asked for this is giving me Snoop
Dogg auntie meme okay I like the
messaging of his jacket when they wear
glasses
I assume that they're high oh yeah big
time he's challenged Eminem to a rap
battle you can't win against Eminem in a
rap battle especially looking like - she
looked like she she doesn't a snake
alive and just went to her dressing room
got her ready and got on the carpet yeah
like I'm fresh do you want to Sabrina
carpenter I've heard that name but no I
only learned about here my last fashion
review video I thought this was an
interesting look she looks like kind of
a cast member from rent it's also fun
and interesting and cool if they were to
remake me and teacher today look while
she saw being a crime that was the last
one how do you feel I feel
but we did a lot but I don't remember
anything I know anytime I do any of
these videos one of my why am i judging
anyone elses wardrobe I would have the
same four things every day
but do it is exhausting you like there's
a lot of look
no major disasters in my mind usually
thank you for doing this but they're
having fun of course make sure you guys
go check out kuzey channel where can
they find you on the Internet I don't
know youtube.com slash Kingsley and
Twitter and Instagram Kingsley with
three wise why did you do that
the handles videos are super super
funnier than that I don't know Alessia
Cara oh no I bet I didn't know that with
her yeah me either I thought this was
andrea russett comfortable she's
basically wearing like ski pants with
some Doc Martens oh my god I have to
talk to you about something what we're
done
[Laughter]